Good morning, everyone. I'm Sarah Tajjan from the Children's Hospital of
Philadelphia. I'm delighted to welcome you to this very far, far room away
in Room 28 for a wonderful education session today
on small patients and big problems, precision medicine
approaches for childhood cancers.
I'm joined today by my good colleagues, Dr.
David Ziegler from Sydney Children's Hospital and Cancer Institute, and Dr.
Catherine Janeway
from Boston Children's and Dana-Farber Cancer Institute.
We will be providing three talks today for you on precision
medicine in childhood CNS tumors, bone sarcomas, and
leukemias. Each talk will be about 20 minutes, and then we'll have about
10 minutes for questions after each speaker.
I will ask you all in the audience, number one, we're a little bit lonely up here,
so please feel free to move forward so you can hear and see better.
But if you have a question, please go up to the microphone afterwards because we
have a robust online presence. And please give us your name and where you're from
before you ask your question. And with that, I will introduce Dr. David Ziegler.
Thanks so much.
Okay.
Okay, so thank you so much to the organizers for inviting me to speak and
for everyone
here who managed to find their way to the very last room in the
convention center,
where they've hidden the best talks, I think, the best topic, at least,
on pediatric cancer. So I'll be talking about
precision medicine in childhood CNS tumors and
beyond, just to give me a bit more scope to go a little bit beyond CNS tumors
as well. And I wanted to start just with a few basic concepts about
precision medicine, particular, I think, bugbears of mine.
I'll focus on some of our results from Australia and our precision
medicine program and the Zero program and really talk about the
application of
global
precision medicine programs for CNS tumors, both high-risk
tumors, which has been the main focus, but also
non-high-risk tumors, which I think is also particularly interesting.
So starting off with a very simple question of what is precision
medicine, and I think when we think about it, we think about really the first image
there, the magic bullet. Finding that genetic change in a tumor,
finding the drug that targets that genetic change, and really
finding that magic bullet that will wipe away the tumor for that patient.
But really, I think that's a small number of patients
that that paradigm actually fits.
And more often, precision medicine really can be about
fine-tuning the treatment for different patients using
that genomic information that we can gather through whatever testing we're
doing to adjust the treatments that we're giving,
understand better prognosis for that patient, or work out
different ways to modulate their treatment.
And also increasingly,
really about using it as a diagnostic tool.
So not necessarily about finding the magic bullet, but about using the
genomics to understand what is the tumor that we're actually treating,
rather than just looking down the microscope like we've been doing for hundreds of
years, looking at the tumor and making the diagnosis based on the genetic
profile of that tumor.
So that's precision medicine, but what is targeted therapy?
And again, I think, we think about this, and we've got that general
concept like I introduced of the magic bullet.
But when we think, "Well, here's a targeted therapy.
We've got a pathway. We've got targets.
We give a drug that specifically attacks those targets." However, in this
case, the drug is CP, which is actually cisplatin.
So I think every drug that we use is in some way a
targeted therapy. Every chemotherapy essentially has a target.
And even those drugs here that we think of as more targeted
therapies, less generally cytotoxic, when you look at...
And these are just some of the tyrosine kinase inhibitors, actually have
multiple different targets.
We like to think we know what the targets are and what we're targeting, but often
the drug may actually be doing different things or hitting other targets, both ones
we know about, but are also ones that we don't know about.
And then, of course, we have drugs where we do really know what the
target is, and CDK4/6 inhibitors is a very good
example. But those pathways may be so complex that
actually while we know what the drug's hitting, we don't really know what the
biomarker is. And I think CDK4/6 inhibitors is a really good example
where they're used as a standard
tool in adult breast cancer. But in pediatric cancers
and indeed many other cancers, we still really don't know what the biomarker is
that we should be targeting or which genomic
signals or pathways are the ones that tell us this is the right
tumor for which we should be trying these different inhibitors.
So this is the simple paradigm that we think about with precision
medicine and targeted therapies.
We find the pathway, we find the gene that gives us the switch,
and we switch it off, and we
kill off the tumor.
Again, the reality is most tumors that we're dealing with have pathways that look a
little bit more like this. And yes, maybe there is one of those
wires that if we find it, that's the real tumor driver, and if you switch it off,
then you will switch off everything that drives it.
But more often there may be wires and switches there that are
doing nothing or maybe there's multiple pathways that will be
activated, and we need to switch multiple of these drivers off.
So these are all the things we need to think about.
It's not just as simple as finding a genetic change and finding a drug,
but it's really understanding how those different pathways and targets
and everything work in those different
tumors.So putting this
together, there's multiple different programs around the world trying to
get all this information and work out what we can do, how we can use it
to enhance the outcomes for our patients.
In Australia, our program's called the Zero Childhood
Cancer Program, and many different
programs use different
genetic testing. Sometimes it's just a gene panel, sometimes it's whole
exome. In Australia, we use a whole genome, RNA-Seq,
DNA methylation profiling, and indeed, try and do drug screening and animal
modeling as well and try and pull that all together initially for the
highest-risk patients. And so the question is really how useful is this?
It's something that we're all trying to do.
In Australia,
most of our patients or the largest group is
high-risk brain tumors as well as then sarcomas and other
cancers. So how useful is doing this for all this patient group?
And
when we started our program, this was actually one of the first patients who
came through the program. It was a patient, a young infant who had a high-grade
brain tumor initially thought to be an ependymoma.
Later, the pathology and the sequencing helped us realize it
was actually
a high-grade glioma, and we found a TRK fusion.
This was right at the time that larotrectinib had just been developed.
It actually wasn't yet available in Australia, but we managed to get it
flown in for this patient, and this was really the
case that we're looking for where we're
looking for that magic bullet. So this was a patient who had failed
chemotherapy, radiation therapy, was in palliative care, had literally
just been sent home to die. We were waiting for this drug to be flown
in. This is really that paradigm
of the highly targeted drug that really doesn't have
almost no off-target effects, hits the
target that we're looking for. It's available in a syrup form,
so ideal for infants and young children.
And indeed, this patient had an almost miraculous response with
widespread disease throughout her brain.
Literally had to call her in as she'd been headed home,
sent home for palliation, called her back in, and she went from a child who
was unable to get out of bed to within a
couple of months was walking, talking, and dancing into clinic with
complete resolution of her disease. So this is the dream.
This is what we're looking for. This is the magic bullet.
But in reality, TRK fusions, as an example, are very rare.
They occur in rare tumors or rarely in common
tumors. So the question remained, how useful is doing all
this sequencing for the majority of our brain and other
high-risk cancer patients? And so we published this a couple of years ago
when we looked at what is the result, the impact for our patients.
Essentially, the bottom line is that doing what
we thought is really the most in-depth sequencing that you can do for these
patients, in 71% of these high-risk patients, you can find a
therapeutic target. 5% had a change in diagnosis,
and in those with a therapeutic target, when you do give them
a targeted treatment, in
the majority, we were either seeing disease stabilization or indeed objective
responses, both in the solid tumors, but also,
as per this talk, in the CNS tumors as well.
So the majority who you can match to a targeted drug were
actually getting some clinical benefit of some sort.
But these are very high-risk patients. They've failed multiple therapies.
Are we really helping them in the long term?
Sure, we might see a response, we might see a change in an MRI scan,
but is this really improving the prognosis for these patients, most of whom we
know are not going to survive in the long term?
And so we were able to answer this question more recently when we
actually followed up the first few hundred of these patients on the program,
and followed them in the longer term for those who we'd
followed for at least three years.
And actually, for the first time, we're actually showing that we are improving
their survival, both in terms of progression-free survival and
overall survival. When you look at what we call precision-guided therapy,
so these are patients with a genomic aberration that we can target,
they did get the matched
drug to hit that target. And we compared it with
those who got an unguided therapy, in other words, another novel therapy, perhaps
on a clinical trial, perhaps that their clinician got access to but wasn't matched
to their genomic findings. And there was a clear,
highly significant, both clinically significant but also
statistically significant difference in their outcome.
And also, we're able to try and start to answer some of those questions about what
is it that we should be targeting, like that map of
the image that I showed you of so many different wires, so many different
pathways, in many cases, many different targets.
Which are the ones we should really be going after?
Sometimes we might find a fusion, a mutation,
a copy number variation, high RNA expression.
And we did see, for whatever you're targeting,
some degree of response. So whatever you're targeting, you do see some clinical
benefit. But when we looked at the survival of these patients is when you actually
start to see a clear difference. And it had been
hypothesized
by many different groups and different publications that maybe it's the fusions
that give us the best response, and that's actually what we saw here,
that if you can target a fusion,
then you're actually getting a better response.
Not that you don't respond to other targets, but there is a clear differential
in
clinical benefit based on what you're actually
targeting.And moreover, when we looked
at all the different prognostic factors, when you combine them, you can actually
start to see a real difference. So in particular, if you find something that's
a fusion,
if you're using a drug where you have the highest level of clinical evidence, what
we call--
I think Katie Janeway actually came up with the different
tiers, which we adopted, of Tier 1 clinical evidence, and you use
that early, then you really have a very profound improvement in
survival. And so again, really, I think helpful information to clinicians that
if you're finding a very good target with a good drug that's been
clinically tested, you shouldn't wait.
You should be trying to give that drug to that patient
earlier rather than keeping it in your back pocket and waiting till
they're nearing the end, as I described
earlier.
So we're seeing a clinical benefit, but then, there's some of these
worst of the worst patients where the question has remained, well, are we really
helping those? And in this case, we were looking particularly at those with diffuse
midline gliomas or DIPG, so the worst of the worst brain tumors,
no known effective treatment,
radiation therapy being the only therapy that has any palliative
benefit, but no systemic therapy that we really know improves survival.
And there was a question, are we really helping these patients who we
know are all not going to survive in the long term?
So we looked particularly at these patients with diffuse midline glioma.
This is currently
in press, hopefully will come out soon.
And what we saw when we just looked at overall survival, any patient who got a
precision-guided therapy, we did see a
12 versus 21-month difference in survival, which wasn't
statistically significant. But this is a very
heterogeneous group of patients receiving different treatments at different time
points. So a little bit hard just to compare those two
groups directly. So we tried to try and find a time point where we could
actually match the groups more evenly.
So we looked at those patients who had progression and then got a
different treatment, either re-irradiation, which is now
used by many as a standard of care, or an unguided treatment, as I
described before, or indeed, a precision-guided treatment with
or without radiation therapy. And here we actually see for the
first time that indeed, if we can give a precision-guided treatment to these
patients, we are actually improving both their progression-free survival
and overall survival, compared to just
either an unguided therapy or just re-irradiation.
And I think this is really the first time we've been able to show this.
Indeed, these patients are still not surviving in the long
term, but we are starting to make a difference with these patients if
we can find the right target and the right drug to match them.
How do we improve this further? I think it goes back to what I was saying earlier.
We need combination therapies. We need to be able to hit multiple pathways at the
same time. But at least this is telling us, yes, we are on the right
pathway, and we can potentially make a difference for these patients if we can
find the right drug to match the right target.
So that's all our high-risk patients where we are, I think, starting to make a
difference. We still have a long way to go.
How can we improve those survival curves even more?
And I think combination therapies and novel agents is the way we can do that.
But what about all the other patients, all our non-high-risk patients?
Is this approach actually useful in that setting?
And
again, if we just take a step back and think about the different ways we
use precision medicine,
really,
using that genomic information has now become the standard of care for all brain
tumor patients when we look at what we call DNA methylation profiling.
So many of you will be familiar with this, but for those who aren't, each
gene can be either methylated or unmethylated as a
way to control that gene's expression.
And there's now these chips which you can use that will just look at the whole
genome and tell you which genes are methylated versus unmethylated.
And this was really pioneered by the group at Heidelberg, led by
people like Stefan Pfister and David Jones, where you get now
a report and a readout, which in this case is just
actually--
The image that you often see on these reports actually just infers from that
information the gene expression levels and copy numbers.
So you can see the chromosomes across the bottom,
and you can get some information about chromosome gain or loss or indeed,
gene amplification, in this case, EGFR amplification.
But really what the main
goal of this is to look at that whole pattern of methylation versus
unmethylation across the whole genome and look at that pattern to
see where that tumor matches with other tumors.
And this has been evolved over the last decade since it was first
discovered. And that really is critical information that
we now use to help tell us genomically where this tumor
matches with other tumors. And you essentially get a readout and a score to
tell us how closely, based on that whole DNA methylation
profile, this tumor matches with other tumors and can
then be integrated with the pathological report in about at least
10% of cases can actually change the diagnosis.
And
not just change the diagnosis of the whole group, but actually give you important
information within subgroups of tumors.
So, we now know, for example, or we've known for over a
decade, that medulloblastoma really divides into four
main subgroups of genomically distinct tumors, the WNT,
Sonic Hedgehog, Group 3, and Group 4 tumors, which is
now again the standard of care. ButWe now know within those groups
there are more subgroups. And so with what we call the non-WNT, non-sonic
hedgehog groups, we now know that there are actually eight distinct
genomically very different subgroups of medulloblastoma.
And while we can divide the main subgroups and
tell the difference between them histologically and looking at
IHC,
to really understand these subgroups, you really need DNA methylation profiling
as the only real test that can actually help us understand which
of these subgroups it falls into. And with very different information, for
example, group four, as you can see here, has a very good prognosis
with a very good survival curve. Group eight appears to have a good
prognosis but has these very late relapses.
Group three has a very poor prognosis.
So it gives us very important information.
People, I think, off-study are
trying to now use that information, but we still don't actually know how to
clinically apply it. So we really still need clinical trials that will help us
understand, can we use that prognostic information and different
molecular stratification to change the outcome for these patients.
So that's DNA methylation profiling, but can we do this whole
integrated genomic sequencing for these non-high-risk tumors
and not just change what we
understand from the DNA methylation profile, but understand and even find
treatment targets and change their outcome?
And so we're actually now doing this in Australia for all children with cancer,
not just the high-risk cancers. And when we started to do this, actually had a
bit of
controversy, I should say, from some clinicians said, "We're not going to send you
any low-grade gliomas," for example, "because we know these all do well, and we
really don't need any of this genomic information to help with these patients."
So
as we've started to roll out this non-high-risk cohort, we were doing all this
in-depth DNA sequencing. We looked
specifically at the first group of patients with low-grade gliomas, in this
case, pilocytic astrocytomas. And actually what we found was that in
94% of cases, we could identify a therapeutic target,
the KIAB RAF fusion being the most common and well-established target, but
other molecular targets as well, which importantly, many of these wouldn't actually
be found on more standard panels or more routinely
available clinical tests. So very high
clinical benefit in terms of just
targets we can identify. In other low-grade gliomas, so
not just pilocytic astrocytomas, we found even
more different targets. So again, in this case,
71% where we found actually something targetable, and in many
other cases, not necessarily targetable, but of important prognostic
or diagnostic information that helped change
the treatment for that patient. And indeed, when we surveyed the clinicians for the
vast majority of these non-high-risk, low-grade tumors, they said this
genomic information was actually very helpful for them clinically.
And indeed, it's not surprising because we've now known for a decade that
low-grade gliomas are driven by what we
call a single pathway disease. So they all have aberrations, almost all
in this MAP kinase pathway, which is
important because it's
usually the only target, and it really goes back to this paradigm that we talked
about at the beginning. This is really the low-grade tumors actually fits this very
well, where you have a single pathway, sometimes a single genetic change, and
if we can switch off that change, we can really help these patients.
And this has been shown in those patients with a BRAF
V600E mutation, where a randomized trial was
published
recently in the New England Journal of Medicine, where if we give these patients a
targeted combination therapy, dabrafenib, BRAF inhibitor
with trametinib, a MEK inhibitor, we see a significantly better
both response and survival compared to the standard of care with
chemotherapy. And so these targeted agents have now become the standard of care
for these BRAF V600 mutant tumors.
But if we go back to this pathway, we got to remember, these
BRAF mutant tumors only make up a very small
percent. The majority are actually driven by this BRAF fusion.
And we
now pre-clinically and unfortunately clinically also
know that if you get this paradoxical tumor activation,
if you treat these tumors with a first-generation BRAF
inhibitor.
And so really, we can't use those inhibitors for these most common driver
that we see in these patients. We can use the downstream
targets or MEK, and the studies have now been concluded showing
that MEK inhibitors in these BRAF
fusion-driven tumors or NF1 mutant tumors actually has a
clinical benefit. Seems to be about the same benefit as we see with the
standard of care of chemotherapy, but that hasn't actually been compared
directly in a clinical trial. What's, I think, created
a lot of excitement is now the second-generation inhibitors, and
toverafenib is the lead in this group of
inhibitors, where we can actually target not just the BRAF mutation,
like the first-generation inhibitors, but target the fusion as well,
which you can't do because you get that paradoxical activation if you use
first-generation inhibitors. But toverafenib and others are
pan-RAF inhibitors that can actually successfully switch off this driver.
And what we're seeing now
with these pan-RAF inhibitors is really quite
unprecedented clinical responses,
slightly different depending which criteria you use to measure response, but
really quite dramatic and unprecedented response rates
where normally with these tumors, we're happy just to see a tumor being stable and
not growing. But in this case, we're often seeing tumor regression and
significant clinical benefit.And this is now being compared head-to-head
in a randomized trial as should these inhibitors be the standard of
care for these patients.
So in summary, precision medicine has a growing role, particularly in
childhood brain tumors. It's not just about the magic bullet, but
also a diagnostic test, both in DNA methylation profiling
and the next-generation sequencing.
We are definitely seeing an improvement in outcomes, even in those
highest risk, most aggressive tumors.
But really, almost unexpectedly, it's the low-grade
tumors with that single pathway disease that we are also seeing
very dramatic important clinical benefit.
And I'll just finish by advertising, if any of this is of interest to you at all,
please, you've still got time to come to ISPNO in
Sydney at the end of June, which will be filled
with exciting precision medicine in children's brain
cancer. Thank you.
Thank you, David, for this great talk. He's now open for questions.
Hello.
Ryan Roberts from Nationwide Children's. Great work.
Love what you've been doing. I wanted to ask a question.
I wonder if we're to a point now where we can
operationalize this. I think so much of this has been done in the research setting,
and so often, especially in the rare cancers where this really has the
greatest potential, I think,
we hit up against guidelines where we know exactly what the patient needs,
but the guideline's not there that gives us access to the drug for that
patient.
Do we think that we can get to a place where we operationalize this
process, and the process becomes the guideline for the rare tumors?
Yes, as they say, from your lips to God's
ears. We need to build this in, and I think it's different in different
countries and different jurisdictions. We're looking at that in Australia.
How do we get this built in as the standard of care?
I think even simple things like, again, this is particular to
Australia, we want drugs to be approved, not just as they have been
for decades. Our BRAF inhibitors were improved for melanoma.
What we want is BRAF inhibitors to be approved for patients with BRAF
mutations. And that is starting to happen, but I think it needs us to
advocate for that and speak to the decision-makers.
And I think we have some great examples.
NTRK is linked to the change,
but that's very specific, right? And then we have certain
diseases where we've linked that.
But I wonder if we could create criteria where if you meet this and
this and this, and you actually outline that very, very well, where you have very
high confidence with these criteria that that's the right drug for this patient.
Yeah, exactly. I agree. And I think that needs us to be, as I said, speaking to
those decision-makers and telling them, "This is what you need to be doing,"
particularly for children, particularly children's brain cancer, where they're
all rare diseases, and you're never going to have that randomized trial for most
cases. Yeah.
And even more young adults.
Absolutely.
Shai Israeli from Schneider Children, Tel Aviv University in Israel.
So, this is amazing what the Australians are doing, right?
It doesn't exist anywhere in the world.
So I have two questions related to this.
First is, do you in
addition do germline sequencing?
And the second,
there is a debate
between using whole genome sequencing
approaches to panels. So what
do you think about this?
Yes. So in terms to the first question, yes, we do germline sequencing,
and in fact, just published in clinical cancer research
some of those results. And I think we initially did that, and I think most people
do it,
because you have to do it. In order to understand the somatic environment, you need
to look at the germline. And actually, we had the most
anxiety from clinicians when we started to do that because they didn't want to get
all these germline or didn't know what they're going to do with germline results.
That was when we started. Now that we've been doing it for many years, that
anxiety has dissipated because there's a pretty
simple pathway where they refer to genetic counselors, and it
hasn't created any clinical problems.
And we found, as indeed most people have, a lot more
germline findings than we ever expected.
So about 16% of patients were finding a germline, either
driver or a coincidental finding.
And I think we still need to try and understand how many of them are really driving
the tumors versus how many we're just picking up incidentally.
So yes,
that is part of it. And I think in addition, there's germline
drivers that we haven't identified yet that we still--
Because we're really just looking for germline findings that we know from adult
cancers. But the ones that are specific for pediatric cancers, I
think, need to be still be discovered.
And I forgot your second question.
Panels.
Whole genome versus panel? Yeah. Certainly,
it's very difficult to really accurately compare them.
But
from what we've observed is that everything we've found in a
panel, we'll find in the whole genome, plus more that we
wouldn't find in a panel.
Yes. And the price is getting cheaper, right?
Absolutely. So we actually, when we started, we said, "Well, we'll just do panels.
The whole genome will be for research." We started getting the whole genome
results back faster than the panels, and we actually have stopped doing panels
unless we can't do whole genome for technical reasons. Yeah.
Last short question and short answer.
Of course.
I'm Soumik Saha from Dr. John Presner's lab at the University of Michigan.
I have somewhat of a more general question.
With more high-grade gliomas or high-risk group two medulloblastoma, where
do you see the room for most improvement in our research and
clinical work,
in the context of this kind of whole genome sequencing and
methylation sequencing?
Yeah. So, a big question. Short answer is, I think the key is we
really need combination therapies.
So at the moment, we're finding one gene, we're giving one drug.
We need to work out how we can give not just multiple drugs in combination, but
actually sequentially give multiple drugs, one after the other.
That's how we cure leukemia. We don't just give one drug.
Well,
maybe blinatumomab now, but
we use lots of drugs in combination. I think that's the key.
Thank you.
Thank you so much, David. That's great. And we'll now welcome our next speaker, Dr.
Jane Wei.
Good morning, everyone, and thanks for being here.
I'm just waiting for my slides to come up so I can start them.
Okay. Ah, you're clicking them. I have to click those. Got it.
Okay.
So, I'm going to tell you about two bone sarcomas, osteosarcoma
and Ewing sarcoma.
And I will describe the clinical and genomic
characteristics briefly and then really focus on our recent work
looking at defining biologic subtypes that are associated with
outcomes following standard frontline chemotherapy.
It will quickly become clear that there is much work to be done in this area, and I
really hope to inspire you. That's a very positive way of saying
that in the bone sarcomas, we're quite behind other cancers and
even other pediatric cancers.
And there are several reasons for this,
the first of which is shown on this slide regarding osteosarcoma.
And you can see that osteosarcoma,
if you look at this histogram, is a disease of teenagers and young adults,
with a few quite younger patients and a few older patients.
And that essentially creates
patients where the research and clinical care is split across
traditional pediatric and medical oncology care silos.
The second problem, to quote a colleague of mine,
is that bone is hard. You want your bone to be hard.
But when it comes to doing research, actually bone tumor
specimens are quite difficult material to work with.
And until recently, we really haven't had technologies to
address that problem. And we, to be honest, really haven't had the
sort of community engagement that we needed in order to make
progress. But I hope you'll see that we're
beginning to make progress there.
So osteosarcoma is a primary bone tumor.
There are about 600 cases per year in the United States.
It most often occurs around the knees, and 40% of
patients will have advanced disease, with about half of those having advanced
disease at diagnosis and half having advanced disease at the time
of relapse after completing frontline therapy.
The most common site of metastatic disease is the lung.
Following standard chemotherapy treatment with doxorubicin, cisplatin, and
high-dose methotrexate, the 10-year overall survival if you
have advanced disease at diagnosis is only 25%.
If you have localized disease, that long-term overall survival is
75%.
But in osteosarcoma, our ability to predict
whether you'll survive your metastatic disease or
will relapse after localized disease is quite poor.
For prognostic factors, we use poor histologic response, which
is looking at how many cells are dead after 10 weeks of initial
chemotherapy, and the location of the tumor, and whether or not there's advanced
disease at diagnosis. These, to me, are really observations
of bad behavior rather than a true
understanding of the underlying biology.
And then I'll just mention that for osteosarcoma and Ewing sarcoma, the other bone
sarcoma I'll discuss, there's a very high burden of both
acute and late toxicity and also a high treatment burden.
This chemotherapy and the chemotherapy we use for Ewing sarcoma
is very intense and really removes people from their day-to-day lives.
And finally, in osteosarcoma, there's been no improvement in outcomes in 40
years.
And I'm showing you that in the survival curves above, which
are by decade and are population data from the United States.
That's because chemotherapy intensification, immune checkpoint inhibitors, and
molecularly targeted therapy are ineffective in this disease.
That's in contrast to neuroblastoma, which is shown on the right and has had
successive improvements in outcomes.
In part, in neuroblastoma, that's due to the ability to recognize
distinct disease subgroups, which are defined both by clinical
and molecular features, which are boxed in the red, such as MYCN amplification.
And then to apply the following sort of
approaches, which is to de-intensify treatment for those patients who have very
good outcomes and to intensify treatment, preferably
by addressing a molecular target that you find in those
high-risk patient populations.
In osteosarcoma, while we've known about the molecular features for
quite some time, our lack of progress is in part due to the failure to
identify these biologic subgroups.
So osteosarcoma, as shown in the karyotype at the top and the circus plot below,
has a highly complex genome
characterized by chromothripsis.
It's the cancer type with the heaviest burden or the largest percentage of
cases impacted by chromothripsis.
That leads to universal inactivation of TP53, most often through
somatic rearrangements, deletions in tumor suppressor genes,
including the cell cycle genes such as CDKN2A and 2B, and
amplifications of oncogenes such as MYC, MDM2, and
CDK4/6.
Mutation burden is actually quite low at 1.2 mutations per
megabase, and there are very few pathways that are recurrently
mutated, perhaps with the exception of a low rate of mutations in the
PI3 kinase MTOR pathway.So while we've
known about these molecular features, we've really failed to correlate
these with clinical features and outcome.
And so we really have no biologic subtypes in this disease.
And as I described, we need those to identify therapeutic approaches,
and
equally important, to interpret preclinical data.
So if you don't know how your models that you're studying in the lab map to the
human disease, it's actually quite difficult to apply learnings in the lab to
our patient population. So, I
will talk to you about our clinical sequencing data that we have access
to, and how we've utilized that to begin to
explore these biologic subtypes.
And the importance of clinical sequencing data is that it can be
linked to the patient data, the EMR data.
So we can both look at baseline clinical features and also patient outcome.
So anyway, basically, we've failed to correlate the middle with the left, which
are several patients of mine who've had advanced osteosarcoma, all with
vastly different disease courses.
So I'll tell you about two studies where we've generated
quite a bit of clinical sequencing data.
The first is the Profile Cancer Research Study, which is our enterprise-level
molecular tumor profiling study at Dana-Farber, Boston Children's,
and Brigham and Women's Hospital. All pediatric patients with cancer were eligible.
It started over 10 years ago, and those with sufficient clinically acquired
tissue were subjected to tumor-only OncoPanel sequencing, which I'll tell you
about on the next slide. We've actually completed this project now and are moving
on to another project.
The second study is the GAIN ICAD2 study.
This was a collaborative project between 13 institutions,
which are shown on this slide, and really addressed high-risk extracranial solid
tumors. The OncoPanel test was used here as well.
That sequences exons from about 500 genes and introns from 60
genes, so we could identify short variants,
rearrangements, and copy number alterations.
And it was designed with pediatric input. That's extremely important.
And then we also did RNA sequencing using also a panel-based
approach.
With these two studies, we have
about 2,500 cases that are sequenced and our adolescent young
adult cases as well.
There are limitations. This is targeted sequencing, so again, back to that
debate between whole genome and targeted panels, and it's
tumor-only.
But it is hospital-based sequencing and is linked to clinical
data. So to look at these osteosarcoma biologic
subtypes, we took both of these cohorts together and had 92
patients, but it's going to be enriched for patients with metastatic disease and
those with relapse because of the way that we selected
patients for our ICAD GAIN study. Then we worked with Memorial Sloan
Kettering, who have a similar targeted panel that they've been using
in patients
throughout their institution. Those patients were selected for being localized at
diagnosis. We assessed candidate recurrent alterations for
association with event-free and overall survival, and we were able to collect
baseline clinical treatment and outcome data from the medical record.
I'm showing you the sort of patient demographics and clinical features
were pretty typical for this disease.
And we really ended up focusing on MYC amplification.
None of the other genomic alterations we looked at were
either frequent enough for us to be able to look at associations
in this small patient population or were correlated with outcomes.
So MYC amplification is seen in about 10% of osteosarcomas
in our initial discovery cohort, which is the
Dana-Farber profile and the GAIN study, and
enriched for patients with high-risk disease.
Was
defined as a copy number greater than seven.
That's an absolute copy number based on integer.
Was associated with a worse overall survival shown on the left and
event-free survival shown on the right.
In our validation cohort at Memorial Sloan Kettering, which was localized
patients, they use a different way of analyzing their copy
number in their targeted gene panel test. They use a fold change approach.
Because they do a germline. And their threshold
for fold change was greater than two for amplification.
And here we also show that
MYC amplification is associated with
decreased overall survival and event-free survival.
But we had some unanswered questions regarding MYC and osteosarcoma.
To what extent do MYC protein expression and amplification correlate?
So is MYC copy number status alone sufficient to identify the
high-risk population? And should MYC be explored as a
potential therapeutic target? Which again, would require that the protein was
present and highly expressed. So we had 105
osteosarcoma patients with OncoPanel sequencing and tissue
available for MYC immunohistochemistry.
The MYC immunohistochemistry works quite well, and you can see quite a
differential between negative immunohistochemistry and strong
staining with a group of patients with sort of moderate or
variable staining.
High MYC protein expression was defined in this study as greater than
three-quarters of cells with at least moderate staining or half with
strong staining, which correlates to an H-score of greater than 150 and is
something practical that could be done in clinical practice.
Correlation between MYC copy number and MYC protein expression is
not perfect. While on the upper right in red, there
are a group of tumors with both high MYC copy number and
high protein expression. We also see in blue
cases with
high H-score but without MYC amplification, and in green cases
with MYC amplification without a high H-score.
Again, in this group of patients,
we see an association between overall survival, which is shown on
all of the curves for this study,
and MYC amplification.With a
median survival of 1.5 for the amplified cases and 5.4
for the non-amplified. We also see correlation
between overall decrement and overall survival
with high protein expression,
with a median overall survival of 1.8 years
for high protein expression and 5.4 for low
expression.
If we
look more at a composite
assessment using both the MYC amplification and
MYC protein, if there's both amplification and high expression,
the overall survival is much
worse with a median survival of one year.
If you have non-amplification and low IHC, then
that median survival goes all the way up to 7.2 years.
These findings, I should have mentioned, are controlling for metastatic
disease, and so we see the same pattern in localized disease.
Although I will point out that the combination of amplification and high
expression is very uncommon in localized disease.
This is really a feature primarily of having advanced or metastatic
disease at diagnosis.
With that, I'll move on to the second bone sarcoma I'll discuss, Ewing sarcoma.
To me, it's really the other bone sarcoma.
I care a lot about Ewing sarcoma as well, but osteosarcoma is my first love.
In Ewing sarcoma, there are about 400 cases per year in the United States.
The five-year event-free and overall survival for localized patients is
78% and 87%. And unlike
osteosarcoma, showing on the right sort of
sequential outcomes of Children's Oncology Group trials,
we've been able to improve
for localized patients event-free survival.
So initially, that's been done through the addition of ifosfamide
etoposide chemotherapy to our sort of
prior standard, which was vincristine, daunorubicin, and cyclophosphamide.
And then also intensifying therapy through interval compression.
In Ewing sarcoma, we do have some clinical prognostic factors.
We look at tumor size.
And in some populations, tumor location.
Although it seems with treatment intensification that we've been able to sort of
what we call treat away that prognostic factor.
Here as well, we've looked at necrosis.
In other words, the number of dead cells after we've removed the tumor following
some upfront chemotherapy. But again, these are really observations
of bad behavior rather than correlation with underlying
biology. Unlike
osteosarcoma, Ewing sarcoma has a very simple genome.
It's characterized by a canonical fusion between
EWSR1 and FLI1. Most often, those are FET-ETS
fusions.
And then additional mutations or other types of changes are quite
uncommon. With STAG2 and TP53 being the
only two recurrently mutated genes.
We do see some
sort of arm level copy number changes in chromosome one
and chromosome eight. So here we took a very different
approach to what I described previously.
We looked at patients enrolled on the three most recent Children's Oncology Group
phase-three trials of treatment in newly diagnosed patients with
localized Ewing sarcoma. We used an assay that was
actually developed for circulating tumor DNA called Trans eq, which
combines low-passage whole genome sequencing
with a very small panel to detect some of
these
short variants.
And we used as well STAG2 immunohistochemistry, which I will not
discuss.
The Trans eq panel is shown on the right.
And the reason we did this is because we were working with
samples
with very small amounts of tumor remaining.
So of a patient population of 1,674
from these three prior prospective trials,
we had about 354 unique cases. But most of
those were FFPE samples sitting in the Children's Oncology
Tumor Bank, where we only had three slides available
for our assays.
We were able, with those three slides, to detect the canonical Ewing fusion in
282 patients.
And the 19% here on the upper right where we did
not detect the canonical fusion, I think it's not that they didn't have Ewing
sarcoma. It's more that the input material was such
poor quality that we were not able to detect it.
So those cases were eliminated from the analysis.
What we see here is that
recurrent copy number alterations, which are those segmental copy number
abnormalities,
STAG2 mutation, and TP53 mutations are all
associated with an increased risk of relapse when looked at individually
in this disease. These are sort of reverse survival curves.
I'll just point that out. So over time, we're looking at what's your
percentage chance of recurrence.
And then when we look in a multivariable model, it's really STAG2 mutation
that's associated with an increased risk of relapse in this patient
population. We also see that interval-compressed chemotherapy is
associated with a decreased risk of recurrence, which is what we had hoped to
see. And for each year of age, there's
the hazard ratio of 1.1 for an association
of an increased risk of relapse.
Tumor volume, which I had mentioned has been shown to be
associated with outcome in this disease, was only available for a subset of these
patients.
But when we did look at tumor volume, a larger tumor was
associated with a risk of STAG2 mutation, but STAG2 mutation
retained its similar increased risk of relapse in a
multivariable model in that subset of tumors.So with
these results, we're actually getting to the point where we can start to
create a model of Ewing sarcoma risk groups.
We can create a model as shown on the left, where we actually
provide the variables that we think are most
likely to define outcome. And here we
said STAG2 mutation, TP53 mutation, or other recurrent
copy number alterations or no alterations at all.
And as you can see in this recurrence-free survival curve,
if you have no alterations at all, your recurrence-free survival is
approaching that 90% mark, where you start to think about strategies
like dose
de-escalation of your chemotherapy.
Or we can ask the computer to create a model.
And when we ask the computer to create a model,
the model that gets created includes these molecular
abnormalities, but also clinical features.
And so the lowest risk patients here have a younger age,
have extraosseous tumors, so not all Ewing sarcomas are bone
sarcomas, and have smaller tumor volume.
So what that tells us is that we need to
do a little bit more work with our modeling of outcomes
and integrate some of our clinical features to a greater
extent, and we are working on that.
So I just want to say a word about second malignancies and the findings in this
study around that
complication of treatment. So 3% to 4% of patients treated for
Ewing sarcoma will develop second malignant neoplasms.
The majority of those are related to the chemotherapy agents and
are liquid malignancies, very characteristic
leukemias.
And there's an interesting finding in this study.
If you look at the group of patients who have these recurrent copy number
alterations, I told you that there's an increased risk of
relapse if you have recurrent copy number alterations.
However, if you look at event-free survival, the curves are
overlapping. So there's no
decrease in
event-free survival if you have recurrent copy number alterations.
So we decided to look at cumulative incidence of second malignant neoplasms.
And what you actually see here is that if you have
recurrent
copy number alterations, you have a lower risk of second malignant
neoplasms. If you don't have recurrent copy number alterations, you have a
higher risk of second malignant neoplasms.
We don't
really know if the
sort of underlying reason for this is biologic or not.
But more likely, this is an issue of competing risks.
Because relapse
which generally leads to dying of disease and getting a
second malignancy are in competition with each other.
So you have to not relapse and not die of your disease in order to get a second
malignancy.
So we think what's happening here is that we're revealing
potentially a higher risk of second malignancies in our patients with
sort of good biology disease because they're not going on to progress and
die of their cancer.
But much more work needs to be done here.
It's a very challenging area to work on.
So in conclusion, osteosarcoma and Ewing sarcoma have molecular subtypes defined
by single gene alterations
associated with clinically important outcomes.
For osteosarcoma, MYC amplification and protein expression
are associated with worse overall survival.
These findings do need to be validated.
These are really convenience cohorts, not all universally treated,
although in osteosarcoma, sort of doesn't matter what chemotherapy you give,
outcomes are the same. But indeed, those need to be validated.
In Ewing sarcoma, STAG2 mutation and maybe protein
expression, which I didn't have a time to discuss here, is associated with an
increased risk of recurrence and worse
overall survival.
And the
study I showed you is in fact a validation of previously reported results.
So we actually think that's ready for
action in the clinical trial setting.
But there are remaining questions and ongoing future work.
There are other candidate molecular biomarkers of treatment response and outcome in
osteosarcoma and Ewing sarcoma, such as RNA signatures, epigenomics,
and LOH burden.
So we're really now starting to look, especially in osteosarcoma, beyond
single gene alterations. And that, just to
answer a question that was asked before,
more comprehensive sequencing than the targeted sequencing I showed you is needed
for most of those.
So are these molecular subgroups independent of each other?
Can we apply molecular biomarkers in clinical practice?
Can we leverage insight for therapeutic advances?
And really now we're having to use collaborative approaches to building
clinico-genomic data sets in rare cancers in this disease.
And these are just two ongoing projects that I'm working on.
One of them is a direct-to-patient engagement called Participant Engagement in
Cancer Genomic Sequencing Network. It's funded by the Cancer Moonshot.
And we directly enroll patients online, collected
tumor samples and medical records from their treating institutions, and are
starting to analyze the genomic data here and actually are hoping to
do our first data sharing in the next
six months or so.
In addition, just started is a breakthrough
cancer team focused on osteosarcoma,
and this has a major data-sharing component where we're trying
to look beyond just these single gene abnormalities I've told you about for
osteosarcoma. And then in Ewing sarcoma,
the Children's Oncology Group Molecular Characterization Initiative, which I'm
happy to tell you more about if you're curious,
is now enrolling patients with metastatic Ewing sarcoma and round
cell sarcomas of bone and localized soft tissue Ewing sarcomas and round cells.
And we're hoping to expand it to localized Ewing sarcoma as well.And then
through this initiative there will be RNA
sequencing, methylation profiling, and whole genome
sequencing. Sorry, whole exome sequencing.
So with that, I'd like to acknowledge, in particular, the patients and families who
participated in our molecular studies, members of the laboratory
collaborators, and the Children's Oncology Group. Thank you.
Thanks so much, Katie. Questions for Dr. Janeway? Please come to the microphone.
I promise these guys aren't-
Katie, great talk, and obviously dear to my heart as well.
Do you think we have enough information to start deescalating
therapy in patients with good biology Ewing?
Ryan is a plant.
Nice to see you, Ryan. He's by the way, the one who said
bones are hard.
But anyway, so yes, in Ewing sarcoma within the Children's Oncology Group, we're
actually working on a clinical trial strategy that will be a risk-stratified
clinical trial with the concept there being to study
dose deescalation in our lowest risk patient
population.
So thanks for that question, Ryan.
Yes.
So that's not a clinical question, but mechanistic question.
It's incredible that you found that MYC is
a big prognostic factor in osteosarcoma.
In osteosarcoma, you have also lots of chromothripsis, genomic instability, et
cetera. So I just wonder if like neuroblastoma,
the amplification of MYC is based on extra chromosomal
DNA.
Yes.
And this in itself, there are lots of talks in this
AACR. This in itself provide a very bad prognosis because it's
very hard to target the extra chromosomal DNA.
Yeah, no, that's a great question.
In fact, my AACR planning has to do with extra chromosomal DNA and
other complex genome cancers. So, there will be, I think, a lot of discussion
of that at this AACR. I think it's extremely likely that the
MYC amplifications in osteosarcoma are in extra chromosomal DNA, and there's
some data, not from our group, but from other groups that in fact is the case.
So, yes, MYC is a hard
target to begin with. But I think probably much
worse because of that.
Dr. Janeway, I have a clinical question.
So when we stop typing the pediatric
cancers, do we need to consider about the
emerging drug targets developed for
adult cancers, such as the targets for ADCs
and bispecific antibodies?
Yeah. So great question. The question just is
about drug development for patients of the
age where
these patients are developing cancer.
So, in fact, we were having a little conversation up here before the
session began about the challenge of sort of teenagers and young adults with
cancer. And I think the challenges are
many.
One in the sort of genomic space or precision medicine space we're
discussing here, a project like Zero Childhood Cancer is
phenomenal.
But until now, although David tells me, Dr.
Ziegler tells me that it's improving now have barely been focused
on the pediatric patient population, which only includes maybe
two-thirds of patients with osteosarcoma and Ewing sarcoma, for example.
And so our
efforts to collect large patient populations, which is what we need
to do in this precision medicine and genomic space, particularly in a complex
cancer, are challenged by this split between two silos.
In drug development, we have a similar problem.
And
the problem is on multiple levels.
First of all,
at the institutional level,
there are some challenges, although many of us work very hard on
that.
Accessing trials, for example, from my medical oncology colleagues that I
have open in pediatric oncology that are focused on osteosarcoma and the same is
true the other way. So in the United States, the FDA has said
trials of new drugs like ADCs that are relevant in
osteosarcoma or even Ewing sarcoma should go down to age 12.
But
our very small patient population is competing with a flood of
carcinoma patients who are enrolling on those trials.
So it gets hard to get the patient in.
And if you do get the patient in, it's one or two patients out of 75,
and they're using those trials to look for signals.
So you can't get a signal with one or two patients, particularly in a biologically
complex disease. So that's a problem.
Second,
there is a pediatric drug development in the United States and in Europe sort of,
and other places, focused on pediatric drug development, but it's really fit for
purpose for small people,
like liquid formulation, dosing in small people.
And that actually if anything,
maybe delays the rate at which our adolescents and
young adults get access to these drugs.
So there's a lot to be worked on there. Thank you for asking the question.
Thank you.
Thanks.
Okay. It's my pleasure to round out this session with the discussion of precision
medicine in childhood leukemias, and we'll touch on important topics today in
ALL, AML, and some rare pediatric myeloid leukemias as well.
So I don't have to remind this audience that acute lymphoblastic leukemia or ALL,
has really been a major success story for us in pediatric oncology, and you can
see here shown in these survival curves over the past 50 years, we've really made
dramatic improvements in event-free and overall survival of our patients.
And this has largely been due to appropriate risk intensification
based on underlying genomics as well as measurable residual disease or
MRD at the end of induction chemotherapy.
And we nowWe're in an era for many of our patients with lowest risk ALL, we're able
to preserve good cure rates even with the RBD intensification.
And I think for this patient population, this remains a major goal, even if you
will consider this a bit of precision medicine.
And we certainly in recent years, and we'll touch on this in the coming slides,
have appreciated the power of immunotherapy, and I would like to argue with you
that this is also a good method of precision medicine therapy.
But we are also very interested in moving forward how to combine antibody-based
immunotherapies now also with targeted inhibitors.
And so we certainly know through major collaborative team science and collaborative
work done in very sophisticated next generation sequencing,
that childhood ALL, both in the B subset and the T subset, are
incredibly genetically heterogeneous and shown here on the right are just some
examples of the many subtypes within childhood B-ALL.
And this has been a very exciting time, I think, to marry the important advances
that we have made in genetic characterization of childhood ALL, also with
preclinical functional validation to try to understand which of these subtypes may
be targetable by precision medicine approaches.
I think what remains difficult for us in ALL, however, particularly in
T-ALL, is that many of these subtypes are associated with chemotherapy
resistance and poor outcomes, but we don't yet know how to drug them.
And so a lot of work is continuing to go on to try to understand how we can
match the right patient to the right medicine within these high-risk subtypes of
ALL. And even when we have very compelling biology and
rationale that suggests that a targeted therapy may be particularly relevant for a
child with high-risk leukemia, I think as this group unfortunately also
well knows, access to most promising targeted therapies has remained a major
challenge for us in pediatric oncology.
So I'll start out by talking a little bit about BCR-ABL-rearranged or Philadelphia
chromosome positive ALL, which really for us in pediatric oncology has been a major
paradigm for precision medicine really for the past 25 years.
We now learned in the early 2000s through clinical trials done by the Children's
Oncology Group, as well as our colleagues in Europe, that the addition of the
first-generation tyrosine kinase inhibitor imatinib to chemotherapy could
dramatically improve event-free survival for these patients and
importantly, spare some of these children from the toxicity of hematopoietic stem
cell transplantation in first remission.
Continued work through the COG and other consortia have now credentialed
second-generation inhibitors such as dasatinib when added to chemotherapy.
Although paradoxically, we have not seen an improved outcome for patients treated
with dasatinib compared to imatinib in the PH-positive space for reasons
that we don't fully understand, given the potential for greater molecular
remissions with dasatinib and also greater CNS penetration.
These clinical trials have also through robust correlative biology studies,
also allowed us to define the prognostic impact of important
co-mutations in PH-positive ALL, including Ikaros deletions and
other transcription factor deletions that we think incrementally may add to the
poor prognosis of these patients, although we don't fully yet know how we might
overcome those barriers. And I think that the paradigm of successful
precision medicine in PH-positive ALL has been a huge success and
has also really inspired us to try to understand how we may now apply precision
medicine approaches to other potentially targetable high-risk subsets of
childhood ALL.
And so, of course, the natural succession plan was to look at what we now call the
Philadelphia chromosome-like or PH-like ALL subtype,
which we now know is an incredibly common subtype of B-ALL across
the age spectrum that is associated with high rates of chemotherapy resistance,
MRD positivity, and ultimately relapse.
We also have learned through collaborative genomic sequencing efforts that the
PH-like ALL subtypes are also driven by a variety of
non-BCR-ABL rearrangements that also activate constitutive
cytokine receptor or kinase signaling, and it is hypothesized that these
patients may similarly benefit from the addition of TKIs to chemotherapy to
improve relapse risk and survival.
We now know that there are more than 80 different discrete fusions within PH-like
ALL over the past 15 years. This is an incredibly heterogeneous
subtype now. But for all practical purposes, we can bin patients with
PH-like ALL into one of two major categories.
About 70% of which harbor alterations in the JAK-STAT pathway are
predominantly rearrangements in the cytokine receptor-like factor two or
CRLF2 gene, but also fusions involving JAK2 or the
erythropoietin receptor. And based on robust preclinical data and
anecdotal emerging clinical data, we think that these patients may particularly
benefit from the addition of JAK inhibitors to chemotherapy such as ruxolitinib.
We also know that another 10 to 15% of patients harbor mutually exclusive
alterations in what we call ABL class genes involving fusions of
ABL1, ABL2, CSF1R, PDGFR beta. And
similar to PH-positive ALL, we think that these patients may particularly benefit
from the addition of SRC-ABL inhibitors such as imatinib or dasatinib.
And then finally, there's sort of a grab bag over here if you will, of N of one
type alterations that activate kinase signaling and may similarly be
susceptible to targeted TKIs, although we don't yet know if these are fully
considered PH-like or not.
And so to address some of these questions based on robust preclinical data and
translating that to the clinic through our children's oncology group, we have
recently conducted a Phase II clinical trial called AALL 1521
that was a single-arm study in which we non-randomly added ruxolitinib, a JAK
inhibitor, to chemotherapy for patients with newly diagnosed PH-like
ALL harboring those CRLF2 rearrangements or other JAK pathway
alterations. In the Phase I component of this study, we explored six different
dose levels of ruxolitinib to identify a safe and tolerable dose in the frontline
with multi-agent chemotherapy. And in the second Part II phase, we are
exploring the efficacy of patients treated at the recommended Phase II dose of
ruxolitinib with chemotherapy. This study completed accrual about three years
ago, and we are eagerly awaiting efficacy results in the mature readout,
hopefully later this year.At the same time that we were conducting
this study for PH-like ALL, we also were continuing to conduct
impactful studies in patients with PH positive ALL.
Again, knowing that the burden of cure in our patients is very high due
to chemotherapy-associated toxicity.
And in this international collaborative study through our children's oncology group
and the SVAL consortium in Europe, we also were looking at the potential to
de-intensify chemotherapy and preserve good outcomes for children with PH
positive ALL, perhaps even paradoxically improving their outcomes due to a
reduction in toxic mortality. So patients with PH positive ALL were
all treated with imatinib at this time because this was universally available
across the continents, and then patients were randomized to the intensive SVAL
chemotherapy that was standard of care versus a slightly less intensive but
COG high-risk B-ALL backbone in the experimental
arm. Importantly, we amended this study a couple of years ago to
include patients with ABL class fusions within PH-like ALL, given that
phenocopying of PH positive biology, and we
completed accrual to this study just a little bit early, about a year and a half
ago, with the advent of some of the remarkable data coming out from our
frontline blinatumomab trials that has really revolutionized, I think, our care of
children with ALL, and we'll touch on that in a moment.
But we look forward to hearing outcomes of this trial in the coming years.
So I think a major question for us in ALL now that we have made such remarkable
advances in curing children, especially in the era of blinatumomab, is, is there
still an appetite for targeted inhibitors, or is immunotherapy sufficient, and we
all should all go home? We certainly know that CD19 and
CD22 targeted immunotherapies, both antibody-based and cellular,
have been remarkable in inducing remissions in children with relapsed high-risk
ALL, where remission was initially not
possible. But despite this efficacy, we also know that these
immunotherapies have unique toxicities, and these are not always benign,
particularly in the cellular immunotherapy space.
We don't yet know great biomarkers of treatment success or failure, and it's very
hard to predict this a priori. We also know, especially in the CAR
T-cell space, that many patients have unfortunately developed very
fatal mechanisms of immunotherapeutic resistance, and this has been very
challenging to overcome. And finally, I think as a moment of equity,
we know that CAR T-cells, in particular, are incredibly expensive and really
have inequitable access across the world.
And so it's very difficult to scale this up for most patients.
And so as I mentioned before, we've been very fortunate, both in adult and
pediatric ALL, to realize the remarkable benefit of blinatumomab, really
across the age spectrum. Certainly, our initial trials conducted more than
15 years ago of CD19 and CD22 targeted antibody
immunotherapeutics really changed the stage for our patients in relapse.
And we were very excited in recent trials to be able to move this toward frontline
investigation with a goal of improving relapse-free survival and
potentially reducing toxicity. We now know that the superiority of
blinatumomab compared to conventional chemotherapy is really superior
across the age spectrum. We saw very remarkable results with more than
80% long-term disease-free survival in a pilot study conducted in
Europe by our colleagues in the INTERFONT Consortium for babies with KMT2A
rearranged ALL treated with a single cycle of consolidated blinatumomab,
and these data have held out now for more than four years.
We also were really excited to see the remarkable outcomes of the AALL
1731 study in which children with standard risk ALL were randomized to
blinatumomab-based chemoimmunotherapy versus standard of care chemotherapy
alone. This result was so remarkable that it shut down all of our clinical trials,
and that was a great thing for our patients, although a very difficult thing for us
as clinical investigators. And we also have been pleased to learn very much from
our medical hematology colleagues about the therapeutic potential of blinatumomab
also for adults with ALL being far superior to conventional chemotherapy.
And importantly, our adult colleagues have taught us a lot about the potential for
cure, even with remarkable chemotherapy de-intensification,
which I think remains a major mission for us now in pediatric ALL.
And then finally, I think based on the heels of the success of blinatumomab-based
therapies for patients without PH positive ALL,
we also have learned a lot from our adult colleagues in Europe and in the US in
small trials that have also successfully credentialed the addition of TKIs
to blinatumomab-based therapies, specifically for patients with PH positive
ALL. And this is a strategy in which we're quite interested in bringing forward to
pediatric patients as well.
And so to that end, our successor AALL 2131, or SVAL
2022 study, is really trying to credential a reduced
intensity chemotherapy backbone with early intercalation of
blinatumomab for patients with PH positive as well as ABL class
PH-like ALL. Importantly, based on very robust preclinical
data that emerged from Monique Den Boer's laboratory in the Netherlands and my
laboratory in Philadelphia, we've also realized that one size does not fit all
in terms of TKI selection for patients with PH-like ALL.
And so in this trial, patients with PDGFR beta fusions are
non-randomly assigned to receive imatinib, whereas patients with the other ABL
class fusions and PH positive ALL are non-randomly assigned to receive
dasatinib and then go on to receive early application of blinatumomab and
reduced intensity chemotherapy.
We hope in this trial to credential a reduced intensity chemotherapy backbone that
will nonetheless be curative and less toxic, and try also to understand the
therapeutic potential of this fusion-specific TKI based on very good
preclinical biology.
And now I'm going to turn our attention to my other love, acute myeloid leukemia,
or AML. As you can see here in these survival curves, we've also made
fairly good progress over the last 40 to 50 years in improving survival for
patients with AML in the pediatric domain.
This has largely been due to recognition of appropriate therapy intensification
and also very broad application of allogeneic hematopoietic stem cell
transplantation in first remission for patients with highest risk disease,
either based on genetics or end of induction MRD positivity
again. However, for pediatric patients with AML, we know that cure comes with
great cost, particularly with acute and long-term toxicities in the cardiac and
infectious domains. And unfortunately, in recent years, most of the
improvements that we've actually made in survival for children with AML have been
due to improved supportive care and not because we have new drugs, with the
exception of the CD33 antibody drug conjugate gemtuzumab.For which
we have demonstrated improvements in disease-free survival in specific subsets of
patients, particularly KMT2A rearranged AML through recent
COG and MYCHILD studies in the UK.
We also know through collaborative team science the incredible genomic
heterogeneity of AML, and I will say that precision medicine is really important
to us given these potentially targetable alterations.
As I mentioned before, we are taking a lot of children to transplant in first
remission because we know that chemotherapy alone does not cure them.
Although I will say for specific high-risk biologic subtypes of AML, we
don't always know that early transplant actually improves overall survival for
these patients. And if we can possibly find an Achilles heel within these leukemias
that may be immunable to targeted therapies, we really would like to credential
those approaches and bring them to the frontline.
We know that chemotherapy resistance is a huge contributor to subsequent
relapse. And for children who relapse with AML early within a year of
diagnosis or for any child who relapses after transplant, the
survival historically with salvage chemotherapies is less than 10%.
So we simply need to do better. And we have been very pleased, I think, to benefit
from all of the remarkable knowledge gained by our medical hematology colleagues in
early phase clinical trials now credentialing a lot of targeted therapies.
And we are very hopeful to be able to get these also to pediatric investigation
to be able to credential the right doses and then be able to bring these therapies
forward to the frontline to try to prevent relapse.
And I will make a note that I think that precision medicine for us in pediatric AML
is particularly important. We have not appreciated the successes of
immunotherapies nearly as greatly for pediatric AML as we have in
B-ALL. And so I think that this is really an effort where we need to double down on
precision medicine.
And some of the very successful examples of this for us in pediatric AML, I think
borrowing a page from our adult colleagues certainly have been with the addition of
FLT3 inhibitors to chemotherapy for patients with FLT3 mutant AML.
We've known for a long time that these are some of our highest-risk patients, and
we always have taken the majority of these patients to hematopoietic stem cell
transplantation. Knowing that patients in the adult space could
benefit appreciably from FLT3 inhibitors initially given as monotherapy in
relapse and then ultimately credentialed in combination with frontline therapies
for patients with newly diagnosed disease, this has really been a game changer.
And we've also, through our Children's Oncology Group AML 1031 study,
demonstrated the significant benefit of serafinib addition early in
chemotherapy to patients with FLT3-ITD AML and including
post-transplant maintenance options when available.
However, these trials have also taught us a lot about the impact of co-mutations in
FLT3 mutant AML, and we certainly know that patients with co-occurring NPM198
NSD fusions remain very difficult to treat and do not necessarily
benefit from FLT3 inhibitor addition to chemotherapy for reasons we don't fully yet
understand. And despite the FDA approval now of four FLT3
inhibitors for adults with AML, none of these inhibitors are currently
approved for children. So we really need to do better despite the great data that
we already have.
We also have been very jealous of our adult colleagues with the remarkable success
of BCL-2 inhibition, particularly with venetoclax-based therapies.
This is a high priority for us in pediatric leukemias, but unfortunately, we
have quite limited access and no approval.
We know through adult trials that venetoclax addition to
intensive and non-intensive chemotherapy has been a home run, and we are very
hopeful to be able to credential this also for pediatric patients.
We have been able to conduct some small relapse studies in AML as well as some
frontline studies recently in ALL looking at venetoclax addition to
standard of care chemotherapy. And in anecdotal real-world studies, we've
also shown that this can be remarkably effective even in patients with multiple
relapse. And so we are very eager to bring this forward.
In our current Blood Cancer United sponsored APAL 2020D study, we are
randomizing for children with first relapse of AML to understand
the therapeutic potential of venetoclax addition to fludarabine, cytarabine, and
gemtuzumab chemotherapy and trying to understand at a registration level
if this can improve outcomes and potentially lead to approval for us.
And I will also note that there are other BCL-2 inhibitors out there, and we remain
very eager to have conversations with such companies to be able to
explore these in the pediatric setting as well.
And then finally, I think we've been really excited by the remarkable data coming
out with menin inhibitors in the past couple of years, primarily in adult
AML studies. But we have been fortunate to either include
pediatric patients with some of the biologic relevant
subtypes of leukemias in these trials or to conduct
pediatric-specific investigations alone.
We now know that the now FDA-approved menin inhibitor, revumenib,
has demonstrated remarkable activity when given as monotherapy with 20% to
30% complete remission rates in patients with relapsed acute
leukemias harboring KMT2A rearrangements, NPM198 rearrangements, or
NPM1 mutant acute leukemias. These remission rates are even better when we
combine it with chemotherapy, with about 50% of relapse patients going into
remission again. And I think we've been very excited to hear at ASH and other
meetings the remarkable frontline data now emerging from adults with these
leukemias with 80% to 100% complete remission rates and long-term
survival. We are also now studying this in our COG
AALL 2121 study in infants with
relapsed ALL harboring KMT2A rearrangements, and we also are
doing this in other pediatric institutional studies.
We've also been pleased through the Blood Cancer United consortium in our APAL 2020
case study to look at the menin inhibitor ziftamenib in combination with intensive
chemotherapy also for children, specifically with relapsed acute leukemias
harboring those genetic alterations and have accrued robustly to this trial.
There are, of course, other very exciting menin inhibitors out there with very nice
adult data, and we are in conversations for pediatric-specific investigation
with many of these companies as well.
And finally, of course, our goal of all of this work is to bring menin inhibitors
to the frontline to be able to decrease the relapse risk for these highest-risk
patients.And finally, in the last couple of minutes, I just want
to touch on a couple of near and dear things to our hearts.
We certainly know that there are some very rare pediatric myeloid leukemias that
may be particularly amenable to precision medicine therapies, including
chronic myeloid leukemia or CML. We know that this is not
necessarily the public health menace of pediatric oncology, but this remains a
very important disease given the chronicity of this leukemia and the need for
long-term treatment. We know that the biology of pediatric CML is
potentially more aggressive than that in adults, and we also know that cure comes
with greater cost, potentially, given the endocrinopathies that ensue
from patients receiving chronic TKIs in the developing children space.
We know that most children, fortunately, can achieve deeper mission with chronic
daily TKI monotherapy, but adherence is extremely important
to maintaining these deeper missions.
We also know that there are unique toxicities of TKI therapy, and
over time, with chronic exposure, the ABL1 resistance mutations
can develop. And again, given the potential for decreased linear growth
potential, children with CML who are on chronic TKI
monotherapy require a lot of endocrinology collaboration, potentially for
growth hormone supplementation, management of thyroid issues.
And we are very hopeful that potentially other TKIs such as Bosutinib may have
fewer effects in this domain, but still need to be studied with longer-term
follow-up. And then finally, even though there have been remarkable results
in adults with CML or PH-positive ALL with third generation and some of the
other next-generation TKIs, our access to these important inhibitors in
pediatrics has been extremely limited through early phase clinical trials or not
available to us at all. And then finally, we really need to understand in this
rare patient population which children can be cured and potentially stop
TKIs. We know some data from adults that patients can successfully
stop TKIs temporarily or potentially even permanently, and
ongoing work through our COG AALL18P1 study is helping us to
understand that question a little bit better, specifically in pediatrics.
And then finally, I think near and dear to all of our hearts as clinicians is also
juvenile myelomonocytic leukemia or JMML, a one in a million
diagnosis that I like to call the ultimate RASopathy, given the
clear genetic drivers in RAS pathway mutations.
We know historically that these are very chemotherapy-resistant
leukemias, in which patients receive some chemotherapy
reduction really to maximize the success of allogeneic stem cell transplant.
But historically, approximately 50% of children still went on to relapse.
Very robust preclinical studies that have been led through collaborative work in
the United States and in Europe have identified the therapeutic potential of
targeting a lot of these mutations and aberrant signaling pathways
with various targeted inhibitors.
Of course, MEK inhibitors being, I think, the most important, given these RAS
pathway alterations. And based on recent successes in the
relapse space, looking at the MEK inhibitor trametinib as monotherapy in
children with relapsed JMML inducing about 50% remission rates,
we are very pleased now to be conducting the international TACKLE consortium
2020-004 study that is looking at trametinib for children with JMML
with risk-adapted chemotherapy based on their mutation status as well as
methylation profiles.
So I hope that I have shown you today that we still have a lot of work and a lot of
interest in precision medicine in high-risk leukemias, and I will leave you here
with these major questions. For our patients with ALL, of course, the
who, what, where, when, why of immunotherapies.
But yet I will still argue to you that there is an important role of precision
medicine therapies and perhaps combination with immunotherapies to be able to
further reduce chemotherapy intensity and improve cure rates with less toxicity.
AML remains a major problem for us and I think is ripe for precision medicine
opportunities given the genomic landscape.
And then finally, for these rare pediatric leukemias, it's very difficult for us to
run clinical trials, especially randomized ones.
So how do we ask the right question, potentially once a decade, or how do we learn
a little bit more from real-world data?
And with that, I'll thank you for your attention and glad to take questions.
Camille Choquette from Institute for
Research in Cancer and Immunology, Montreal, Canada.
Thanks for your talk. I was wondering if you, given the great
results you got combining menin inhibitor in AML
and chemotherapy, I was wondering if you thought of
investigating the use of menin inhibitor with venetoclax, for
example.
No, thanks for that great question.
We are very intrigued by the therapeutic potential of venetoclax,
particularly in combination with hypomethylating agents.
I think azacitidine and venetoclax have been very important
kind of real-world therapies for most of us with relapsed
AML patients. This is not FDA approved, so we haven't been able to
conduct a lot of clinical trials in this domain.
But we're very intrigued, especially by now the adult frontline AML studies
that are looking at combinations of hypomethylators with venetoclax and menin
inhibitors. We can anecdotally say in pediatrics this is extremely
well clinically tolerated and we think has high potential to be quite
efficacious. And we would love to be able to study that question more formally in
clinical trials.
Thank you.
Hi. Giselle from Scott Durum's lab,
NCI.
It's always very nice to hear your talk.
You know I'm a very big fan of your work.
I have two questions for you. One is,
from a translational perspective, what
do you think it's currently missing in our preclinical
models or our functional validation
pipelines that slows the
move
from the genomic discovery? We have a
considering amount of genomic data now available
to identify really real drivers
in clinically relevant targets. And the second one
is if you could talk a little bit about
your... opinion regarding
the post immunotherapy lineage switch
that's coming up a lot in recent research.
Thank you.
Yeah. Thanks for those great questions.
I actually think that in the preclinical space, we're doing pretty well.
I think that we've been very lucky both preclinically and now
clinically, to have very robust genomic definition
pipelines. So I think we're actually doing quite well in identifying our patients.
And even in the laboratory space, trying to match those mutations with the right
medicines. I think we've been very lucky in the pediatric space to have
relatively good models with patient-derived xenograft models.
I will say that we are extraordinarily grateful to our patients and families who
biobank on our clinical trials. We literally couldn't do this work without
them. So I think that we've actually done a fairly good job trying to
identify relevant inhibitors or even chemotherapies that may have
particular sensitivity against specific genetic subtypes.
We know that our models are, of course, not fully predictive.
Our patient-derived mouse models are immunocompromised.
They don't fully recapitulate the microenvironmental factors that we know may
contribute to therapy resistance, particularly in myeloid leukemias.
But I think we've actually done pretty well in that space.
For me, the big gap is honestly drug access.
As somebody who works in the laboratory but also works very much in the early phase
clinical trial space, being able to access the right drugs
before we have to wait for mature Phase III frontline clinical trial data from
adults is really challenging. But we also do a lot of these Phase I
clinical trials at risk, where we want to get in early enough where we're able to
access those inhibitors. But I think unfortunately, as many of the clinicians in
this audience knows, sometimes our trials go belly up at the 11th hour
because of negative adult trial data, even if we have a clear biologic
signal. So I think it's tricky, but I think that there's a small
but mighty denominator here who really will continue to push that
translational impact from the labs to the clinic.
And then to answer your second question, we're very interested in lineage switch.
I think many of us, especially in the KMT2A rearranged
ALL space, have realized because these are plastic and stemmy
leukemias, they of course can morph with lineage drift or
switch into myeloid phenotypes biologically, even sometimes rarely
with chemotherapy or with blinatumomab.
Certainly in this era of CD19 CAR T-cells that are very persistent, where
we think that they're really putting a sledgehammer of antigenic pressure.
That is really where we have seen, I think, the most lineage switch.
I don't know about any of the clinicians in the audience, but every single one of
my patients who has developed AML lineage switch, we have not been able to save.
So I think that this is a really important problem.
We are very hopeful that menin inhibitors, because they are attacking the insides
of the leukemias and those critical drivers, may be a little bit more
immunophenotype agnostic in these very stemmy plastic leukemias.
And so we wonder if menin inhibitors can go a long way into helping
prevent lineage switch. There's other preclinical work ongoing
looking at other antigenic targets, specifically in KMT2A rearranged ALL,
like FLT3, where we've also seen, at least preclinically, good
therapeutic potential against both ALL and AML phenotypes, so.
But I think we need to give non-cross-reactive therapy and probably best
combination therapy. And I would love to understand if menin inhibitors and
immunotherapies could help reduce that risk. That's a great question. Thanks.
Good. I think we're out of time today, so I wanted to
thank Dr. Ziegler and Dr. Janeway for their outstanding talks.
I really thank all of you for your attention and being here, and I hope you have a
great rest of the meeting.